did you know that sometimes when we're
not home Bridget likes to watch TV naked
how do you know this oh hey it's that
girl Skylar did she's so hot yeah I have
seen her around campus out there what
sorry to burst her bubble there June but
I've heard that she just recently broke
up with her boyfriend
well my bubble is perfectly intact thank
you because I know for a fact that she
has hooked up with several girls in my
acting class girls our game is afoot
indeed it is Sir hmm you seem very
confident what makes you think you have
a clear advantage over me I'm a lady
she's a lady we already have way more in
common so I'm gonna go over there and
I'm the complement her on her dress I'm
gonna ask her where she got it from and
then we're gonna bond over how ravishing
the broad collection from Zara is that
is adorable because I'm just gonna go
over there and tell her how beautiful
she is because it's not about which is
where you're right you're right which is
why I'm actually gonna get more specific
and I'm gonna tell her that her eyes are
more beautiful than the oceans of Belize
the old Bailey's liner classic but to
Ford because I'm just gonna ease into
the conversation buy her a drink
classy
hila mm-hmm if you take a look at the
lady she is not a tequila lady she's an
elegant lady and an elegant lady
deserves an elegant drink which is why
I'm gonna get her something more like a
1997 Pinot Grigio from Napa Valley like
you can afford anything from the pre mm
I'm gonna go over there dazzle her with
my wit charm and thorough knowledge of
vintage German yachts or you could try
listening you know ask her about her
hopes and dreams be engaged in the
conversation make a conversation more
about her just some free advice for me
to you I was not listening because after
I get her dying laughing with my
exquisite sense of humor while I gently
embraced the small of her back she'll be
unable to resist following truly madly
deeply all the way okay easy Savage
Garden I know a little something about
personal boundaries which is why I'm not
gonna touch the small of her back but
rather graze her arm lightly and
playfully I'm gonna ask her to dance I'm
gonna ask her to play pool and better
that if I win I get to take her on a
date
fire more tequila I'm gonna buy her more
wine
I'm gonna be a perfect gentleman and
make sure she gets home safely I'm going
to subtly hint that we do this again I'm
gonna directly hint that we do this
again I'll bite my lip I'll buy my own
car let's do this let's do it
[Music]
police
[Music]